in this video I'll talk about glycogen
breakdown the enzyme involved in
glycogen breakdown is glycogen
phosphorylase which we would expect to
attach a phosphate regs at the
phosphorylase to y kijun so the way it
breaks down glycogen is it removes a
single glucose unit at a time that's
connected via a now four one four
linkage and it removes it from the
non-reducing ends of glycogen by adding
an inorganic phosphate so that's where
the phosphorylase portion comes in so
this process is called phosphor alysus
so we're going to add a phosphate group
to break a bond so this is opposed to
hydrolysis right hydrolysis was the
addition of water to a covalent bond to
break that bond in this case we're
adding a phosphate to break the bond so
how does this work we start off with a
glycogen chain that's n residues long
where we have this end here being the
reduce or the non-reducing end and this
end over here assuming this chain goes
on further and further and further has a
free Oh H group at the end of Merit
Carbon this would be the reducing end in
any case what ends up happening is back
in tune phosphorylase attaches the
phosphate and actually attaches it right
here to the one carbon and so that
breaks this bond here so this phosphate
group is attached to this dis glycogen
it's an residues long glycogen
phosphorylase catalyzes this reaction
and we end up getting a glucose
1-phosphate this phosphate group is
attached with this one carbon here and
we get glucose one phosphate and the
glycogen chain is now and - one residues
long it's one glucose unit shorter so
notice that we didn't invest in ATP to
get this reaction to go so this is not a
kinase reaction is the phosphorylase
right we're not we're not getting this
phosphate from ATP we're getting this
phosphate just from from somewhere in
the cell now what happens to this
glucose 1-phosphate
we've seen glucose 1-phosphate before
and so what ends up happening is that
this glucose 1-phosphate will be turned
into glucose 6-phosphate
via the same enzyme that catalyzes the
reverse reaction in glycogen synthesis
as far as
overall pathway this would be catalyzed
by phospho gluco mutase now once we
create this glucose 6-phosphate so all
this thing does is move this phosphate
from the one carbon to the six carbon
and once we have this glucose
6-phosphate where does that thing go
so this glucose 6-phosphate will go
wherever we've seen that before we've
seen it in like Ala sis
so what it'll do is it'll go to dialysis
and end up you know going through the
hole in the entire pathway to make ATP
now why do we know that why do we know
that that would happen well when would
we expect by Kajin breakdown to occur
glycogen if we recall is a way to store
glucose right when we break it down well
we break it down we want to free up
glucose because we want energy so when
with this enzyme be active when we want
to break down stored stored you know
glucose and free it up why would we want
to free it up well probably because we
want to break that glucose down for
energy so whenever you want this enzyme
to be active we want it to be active in
low energy states because what this is
going to do is free up a glucose that we
can use to break down for some ATP so
that's why we actually have this glucose
1-phosphate converted into the glucose
6-phosphate to go to glycolysis now this
is actually particularly energy
efficient and why is that well the
reason why is because this g6p allows us
to skip the hexokinase step if you
recall the hexokinase step invested in
ATP and this to get to get this g6p here
in this case when we break off a glucose
from glycogen we skip that hexokinase
step so we end up instead of we end up
skipping the first investment phase or
the first investment step rather so what
ends up happening is that we end up
overall we still have to invest an ATP
at the phosphofructokinase step but then
we have the reactions later to create
for ATP so now we net three ATP right
because we skip the first energy
investment we skip
the first energy investment so it's kind
of cool right as far as a bit
information about glycogen breakdown
whatever what happens at the at the
branch points there's this enzyme called
the debranching enzyme so in the last
video we talked about the branching
enzyme the debranching enzyme has two
different activities one being a
transferase so basically once we've if
we're on a particular branch point and
we've you know nicked off a bunch of
different glucose glucose is once there
are four more a transfer race takes
three of those last four off of the
branch plate and then transfers them
over to the non-reducing end so once
those three those the three of the of
the four when they're attached to the
non-reducing and then they can be
further taken off by glycogen
phosphorylase when there's only one more
glucose left on the chain connected via
the alpha one six linkage we have this
hydrolase enzyme and that basically just
hydrolyzes that last glucose off of the
linkage so it breaks the alpha one six
linkage and it results in a free glucose
in this glucose it's not g6p or GG one p
is just a free glucose so that's just a
bit more in case you were interested but
that's it for glycogen breakdown thank
you for watching